i guess like welcome to marvel like is
there some like initiation thing that
happens when you get to join the marvel
universe
you know i really thought there was
going to be i thought there was going to
be some like cool
dinner party i was going to get to go to
maybe some like
cool initiation i don't know obstacle
course
but no it was just like here's your
marvel email
and had a lot like robert downey jr
isn't all of a sudden like including you
on a group text or something like that
you know come on give me something
yeah some photo shoot with everybody
yeah maybe it's early it's early days
it's early this is true
yeah so i mean what was your reaction to
learning about the show like did you
know about the character drawing this is
a very different
marvel world than we're used to right
right yeah i mean no
when i auditioned i didn't i can't
remember if it even said
marvel you know but it was like shrouded
in secrecy
and had a different name and i was like
oh this is something
you know after a while you kind of you
start to learn the
uh markers for a certain thing you know
if it's a franchise or something that's
like bigger
it's the you could tell right away from
the email right
um so i had an inkling
uh and then i i found out that it was
patent
and and then i found out it was marvel
and then definitely had a moment of like
wait
modoc uh because i
i had some awareness of modok but not
really like all i knew was that he was a
villain and i sort of knew what he
looked like
um but that was it so yeah it was a
whole new world
for me and uh
yeah and i was just really psyched to be
originating
a character in the marvel univer
universe
um who is half latina and so
all of that was really exciting to me
yeah i don't know if you saw the
i guess the trailer that marvel released
today like for phase four
where they showed all the new projects
that they're releasing like movie wise
and yeah that's just so cool it's like
just in terms of representation like
just
yeah the different faces we're finally
getting to see in marvel like
what does it feel like to be part of
that new wave for new face
i mean yeah it's it's it's amazing and
it and it's
incredible and you know um even
know yeah like latinas are a little bit
like missing kind of sort of
in terms of characters so to um
to be originating one you know and our
show is sort of
separate from like the film emcee
film world um so which is good because
it kind of allows us to have a little
bit more
fun with you know like we have iron man
makes an appearance in our show and
uh so but it's so
and to see what it means to all people
of color you know it's
i mean we remember what it felt like
when black panther came out
and just it's meaningful
it's when you see a superhero that looks
like you
and the subconscious implications that
that can have
is everything um so
i'm thrilled to be like a tiny speck of
that
that moved that movement forward and i'm
really excited to see
the films that are going to be coming
out and um it's just an exciting time
yeah is your five year old still as
obsessed with avengers
and marvel as he is he is
a brand new miles morales costume just
so nice in the mail today that he wanted
to wear to school and they said no you
can't wear that to preschool
and uh yeah jordan um our show runner
from modoc
very sweetly put together this amazing
starter pack of comics for my son um
and so we just started diving into some
of that um
so there's a lot of like great
spider-man issues he gave us and
some avenger ones and so it's amazing
yeah it's really fun
yeah so i love your character like wants
to become a super villain
and what i find so interesting about
like this new wave of marvel that we've
had over the past few months
like comedians like yourself are really
getting into
the marvel world like you and patton in
this show juliud louis dreyfus is
playing a villain that we get just got
introduced
and then even like catherine hahn on one
division so what do you make of like
like like like big comedians like
yourself obviously there's been
comic actors before but real true
comedians are now getting into
the marvel world i love it i love to
keep it i love it
um it's so exciting and you know
i think it makes sense too because
there's something kind of
that can be you know comedy can be
really theatrical and i think you have
to have that sensibility
um to play big characters like
superheroes um so you know when you
think of it that way like that
it doesn't feel like that big of a leap
um you know
our show i would say is
very much a comedy so
you know i i can't really like toot my
own horn that much because i'm just like
doing what they expected me to do and
funny
you know i'm not i'm definitely not
pulling off what catherine hahn did
in one division she was so incredible um
and i loved her performance so much and
it was so smart of them to
cast her in that role because that was a
really tough duality that she had to
play
um and i thought she nailed it so it was
thrilling to watch but but there's a lot
of comedy in the pa
in in the comics too you know right a
lot of
that exists in the world so um yeah i
love it
were you shocked at the i'm trying to
think the right word let me if crass
this is the right word but like the
the yes the little non-pg
side of modoc of the yeah were you
surprised at that
i mean yes and no because it was patent
and so
i was like oh this makes sense
you know if you know him or his comedy
and you know if you watch any of us
stand up like um
you know patent's a little filthy
[Laughter]
so but i i loved it because it really
in that sense it felt so different and
so fresh
and you know we've been living with the
superheroes for
a while now and a lot of different
iterations of them
so to me it was really fun
to see a version of this world that was
a little filthier and you know
kind of crass and uh you know that goes
there which feels right if you're going
to be telling a story about a super
villain
yeah and beyond the latina
representation your character is
bisexual right
yes well like i mean i was thinking like
we've hardly seen any lgbtq
representation marvel so far so what's
that like being able to
play be represent that yeah um
i mean amazing i'm a huge advocate for
lgbtq
ia that's like most of my best friends
and my family so
um i i was thrilled to see it
i i didn't know actually too um because
it doesn't play
necessarily in the first season but it's
in the issues that patton and jordan
wrote
um and so when jordan let me know he was
like hey
i think we somehow forgot to mention
which is cool in a way too right like
yeah oh yeah
like so yeah so normalized to them yeah
they were just like oh we we never
mentioned
that by the way and i was like amazing
awesome
great yes who's going to play my
girlfriend
yeah so uh and i i think you know
especially
seeing the response to stephanie
beatrice on brooklyn nine-nine for
instance when rosa came out as bisexual
because that is really
um there's not a ton of representation
for bisexuality
on in our television and movies so
um so yeah so to find out that my
character was as well um
was really meaningful because i saw how
i saw firsthand how much it meant to
people
when we did that storyline on brooklyn
so i'm thrilled
i couldn't be happier yeah speaking of
brooklyn nine like this is just starting
and that's ending have you guys
shot the upcoming season or we are about
midway
through shooting the season yeah we just
wrapped on
episode five so are you like are you
feeling how sick with this are you
feeling
satisfaction how things are going in the
final season
yes i'm really excited for people to see
the final season
i feel like it's the writers really went
for it
um we're doing a lot of
the things that we do that that people
love about brooklyn nine-nine and we're
doing some other things and
we're also getting you know a little
nostalgic and we're having those like
heart scenes and um so it's got
everything and i think it's gonna feel
really satisfying i hope
to our viewers um yeah i'm really proud
of it
yeah i can't wait to see it well
congratulations on this i can't wait to
see more of it but thanks for talking to
me today melissa
thanks so much have a great day you too